[Música]
en Buenos Aires Argentina se celebra la
Cumbre mundial de alcalde c40 donde en
las ciudades reclaman su protagonismo en
la lucha contra el cambio climático en
la inauguración de la cita los
gobernantes advirtieron sobre la
necesidad de acelerar las acciones para
reducir así el calentamiento global y se
comprometieron además a crear 50
millones de puestos de trabajo verdes
ante también antes de finalizar esta
década saludamos a Jorge macri ministro
de gobierno de la ciudad de Buenos Aires
Jorge Gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo América de Francia 24 buena
mañana de viernes y le quiero preguntar
la importancia entonces de esta Cumbre
hacia un futuro verde hacia un mejor
futuro Para nuestras ciudades que
evidentemente recae en nuestro bienestar
Buenos días un placer poder estar en
contacto con ustedes compartir este rato
llegar a tantos televidentes que los
acompañan esta ha sido una Cumbre
central muy relevante todavía lo es No
hemos tenido el cierre de la Cumbre
todavía estamos en plena en pleno
trabajo pero me gustaría tuve la
posibilidad de escuchar un poquito la
columna anterior y y unir ambos a ambos
temas Cuál es el objetivo de defender el
ambiente generar ámbitos de vivir bien
para quien para las personas ustedes
estaban hablando recién de la relevancia
del deporte para que la gente esté sana
no solo digamos el punto de vista físico
muscular o funcional sino también la
salud emocional no hacer actividad
física nos hace bien bueno el ambiente
tiene que ver con lo mismo y si bien Es
cierto que el ambiente es un patrimonio
que tenemos que cuidar todos nos afecta
a todos porque el calentamiento global
impacta en todo el planeta No hay
ninguna duda que que seguramente También
tienen más limitaciones para poder hacer
deporte muchas veces porque no tienen
acceso a las posibilidades de tiempo y
dinero para poder hacerlo son los que
más sufren parte del cambio climático
millones de personas al año tienen que
ser localizadas y algunas hasta mueren
por por ejemplo las inundaciones el
cambio climático impacta en zonas bajas
y en general esas zonas son ocupadas con
vivienda precaria Por quienes Por
quienes son más débiles Entonces si bien
la mirada tiene que ser global tiene que
entender que nos afecta a todos también
tenemos que entender que primero afecta
a aquellos que son El eslabón más débil
muchas veces de la cadena Así que estos
compromisos plasmados concretamente por
todas las ciudades que están aquí pero
más por otras ciudades que vayamos
sumando en el mundo es relevante porque
hace a la calidad de vida de Cada
ciudadano hoy no solo en el futuro
porque a veces esto hablar de futuro
licúa un poquito la percepción de riesgo
este que enfre hoy ya estamos sufriendo
el cambio climático hoy se lleva vidas y
hoy afecta a mucha gente Jorge bien lo
decía evidentemente la crisis climática
es algo que estamos sufriendo en la
actualidad que está afectando a pues
poblaciones enteras en nuestras ciudades
que los obligan digamos a migrar de sus
territorios porque no pueden habitar
donde están actualmente qué compromisos
concretos digamos se quiere alcanzar en
esta Cumbre que tengo entendido termina
también el día de hoy para ayudar a
estas personas para mitigar digamos los
efectos de este cambio climático que ya
está está con nosotros
Bueno lo interesante Ayer fue que Mark
watch que es quien coordina el c40 no es
alcalde es casi el corazón latiente un
equipo de mucha gente que trabaja en el
c40 nos puso en alerta respecto que son
muchas las ciudades que ya están
trabajando en carbono cero emisión o sea
tener un equilibrio entre lo que emiten
y con lo que capturan pero todo eso
tiene que duplicarse en los próximos dos
años Así que el compromisos concretos de
varias ciudades que se comprometen en
Solo dos años a lograr esos objetivos lo
mismo tenemos que lograr en la
generación de nuevos espacios verdes la
posibilidad de transformar edificios
públicos y privados como está haciendo
la ciudad de New York por ejemplo en
este momento este sirve digamos que sea
que tengan certificación por ejemplo el
ID todo eso requiere inversión pero lo
interesante que se está tratando en esta
Cumbre es que también es económicamente
viable y hasta puede ser un negocio
cambiar el perfil de de tu de tu
actividad y ser digamos sensibles claro
al ambiente porque porque hay un mercado
que está buscando alimentos producidos
de esa manera que valora las empresas
que tienen ese compromiso que valora los
gobiernos que tienen ese compromiso y
les renueva mandato en función a ese
compromiso hay una sociedad que nos
observa toma decisiones todos los días y
es falso uno de los dilemas que hay que
romper y me parece muy importante es que
hay una tensión entre desarrollo y
equilibrio ambiental falso se pueden
lograr ambas cosas Me ha tocado ser
alcalde hoy estoy en la ciudad de Buenos
Aires y hemos logrado siempre ese
equilibrio entre desarrollo y equilibrio
ambiental la ciudad de Buenos Aires se
muestra de ello pero muchas ciudades en
el mundo También lo son Jorge le quería
preguntar cómo hacer para para lograr
esto no para que realmente estos
acuerdos que evidentemente son
beneficiosos para todos nosotros que
vivimos en estas ciudades sobre todo de
nuestra región Cómo hacer para que no se
queden papel y realmente
llevarlos a cabo no acaba una corrupción
tratar de acabar con el problema tan
grande que tiene nuestra región de
América Latina del Caribe como es la
desigualdad para que todo el mundo pueda
tener Y ser beneficiario no de estos
avances Y estos desarrollos en nuestras
urbes
Bueno ayer lo decía Horacio Rodríguez
larreta El jefe de gobierno de la ciudad
de Buenos Aires que es vicepresidente
representando a latinoamérica y él lo
dijo muy claro el único cambio real Es
el cambio que se sostiene en el tiempo y
que perdura si no no impacta a la gente
con los compromisos pasa lo mismo si
venimos firmamos un papel como tú bien
decías y Simplemente nos vamos a casa
nada cambia Entonces cuál es el
compromiso del c40 seguimiento
management Con permiso que se asumen
compromisos que se controlan y ayer
veíamos justamente en la presentación es
eso hay objetivos específicos para el
año que viene para el que sigue y
también más largo estamos mirando una
agenda 2050 pero 20 50 es lejísimos para
muchos de nosotros no vamos a estar en
el cargo tal vez no tengamos la suerte
de estar en esta tierra tenemos que
hacer todo pensando en ese futuro pero
también impactando ya así que el c40
tiene un compromiso de follower de
seguimiento de management de control de
que cada ciudad que se comprometa nueva
y también
los privados esto es fundamental tenemos
que entender que las empresas privadas
están privadas también y aquí en este
c40 había un Forum específico de
empresas privadas son muchísimas las que
tienen un espíritu filantrópico para
acompañar esta cosa Hay fondos en el
mundo que asisten a gobiernos o empresas
que no pueden hacer este con las nuevas
necesidades
digamos de inversión tecnológica para
hacerlo Pero como como tú bien decías el
desafío es hoy
asumir un compromiso controlarlo hacer
mal seguir volver a controlar en un año
y el c40 tiene ese objetivo Y esa tarea
y la continuidad no Jorge también tan
importante que los gobiernos de turno
entiendan que hay que tener este
continuismo para pues beneficiarnos o
todos que no es algo político es algo
que se debe hacer por el bien de la
humanidad prácticamente por nuestra
supervivencia